back in 2010 Chelsea Manning who we'll
speak to in a moment downloaded nearly
750 000 classified and sensitive
military and diplomatic documents during
her service as an intelligence analyst
in the U.S army she then sent those
documents to WikiLeaks it was one of the
largest unauthorized disclosures of
government documents in American history
she was convicted of 20 charges
including Espionage and theft and
sentenced to 35 years in prison the
longest sentence of its kind ever back
in 2017 though President Obama commuted
her sentence and she was released after
serving nearly seven years now Manning
is the author of the new book
readme.txt or readme.txt it's
significant to the story it Chronicles
her life growing up in Oklahoma her time
in the military her incarceration and
eventually her release Chelsea Manning
is here for her first interview about
the book Chelsea good morning good
morning thanks for having me thank you
very much for being here uh first
there's a lot in the book we're not
going to get to everything people should
read it it's a real book it's sharply
written it's real it's raw I enjoyed
every page of it really thank you I
people will take away from it what are
their walking away ideas so there have I
have a I haven't really been able to
tell my version of events I haven't
really been able to tell my story uh and
so this is the first this is sort of my
first draft or if you will of history
from my perspective while there is the
uh well I did testify a little bit
during the court martial my voice has
been kind of lost throughout this whole
process and I feel like that's going to
be the main takeaway I think the second
takeaway for this book is going to be
that this is uh this is where I come
from this is what this is who I am now
and how the events that of the last 15
years have transpired to shape me and
this is a coming-of-age story yeah so in
that that story I mean your rise to
prominence is the disclosure of all
these secret and classified documents uh
and you go through that there was no one
breaking point that led you to do it
right people should read the book to
find out why it happened but could you
talk about what your goal was and
looking back now whether you think you
accomplished it right so I think that
one of the primary goals that I had was
uh to try to
I always had this sense that uh
especially whenever I was in whenever I
was actually on the ground in Iraq uh
that there was the story that was
happening on the ground and I always
consider myself a very you know informed
citizen uh prior to this and very well
trained at my job and there was this
just cognitive dissonance between what
what was being told to the public and
what was being shared with the public
and what I was actually seeing on the
ground and I think that that was one of
the main drivers was this immense
cognitive dissonance that I had
regarding the
um regarding the story that was being
you know portrayed how the wars were
being portrayed especially after uh the
Obama Administration come in you write
in the book that you didn't consider
what the cost for your personal freedom
would be in this disclosure no one had
gone to prison for something like this
right ended up being a very steep cost
that you paid uh was it worth it is the
world a better place well I you know I I
don't view it through that I don't view
it through the lens of whether it was
worth it or not I just I am very glad
that you know that the information is
out there and I think that you know
people can review it themselves
unfortunately I can't I can't talk about
it all I can't talk about it all and
there's some redactions of the book
because we went through the Government
Review process so
um you know it's very it was very
difficult to try to tell the story but
when you tell it well you really do
because I've got a childhood in there
it's got the the service overseas and
it's got the aftermath even in the
aftermath there are people on both sides
of the political aisle who say you're a
Trader you committed a crime to rise to
prominence even if you were right you
did it the wrong way what do you say to
those people I don't really encounter
them very often so I I don't really it's
mostly I'm asked by journalists for this
question so just it feels kind of dated
like I think that there was more of that
a few years ago but I just I'm not
really encountering like the same
criticisms as I as I would have in say
2010 or 2013. so you're in a no regrets
state of mind right now uh I'm not
viewing it that way I'm I just I am very
forward thinking um and I want one of
the reasons is why I wanted to write
this book is to get past this period in
time you know I I think that we're
entering a very unstable period of time
and obviously uh you know just sort of
who I am and the the way that I analyze
the world I have a lot of concerns about
the future I'm also optimistic about you
know how we can overcome some of the
challenges that we have ahead of us
there's an amazing moment in the book
where you've uploaded all these
documents to WikiLeaks and then at the
same time you're done with secrets in
your personal life and you begin to be
more public about your transition right
that's a big part of the book your fight
to transition while in prison in a
military prison right what do you want
people to take away from that part of
the book uh I mean and I I I'm just
trying to tell what my experience was
um you know obviously I needed access to
care and I think that um I got that
um you know it took a little bit of
fighting eventually I got that access to
care in the end yeah um and uh and yeah
you know it's it hasn't really even been
you know being trans can sort of be I
think
um turn into something that more than it
is because you know just once you're
once you go through the transition
process you sort of finish like you've
sort of integrate into society and so
you know like I'm very excited about
that part but yeah it was definitely it
was definitely a very difficult road to
travel on yeah a very difficult World
well we're glad to see on the other side
of it uh you are DJing again first time
in 15 years recently in Brooklyn I read
all about it right the uh the music is
uh I think too hip for me but big fans
out there are you gonna do it again yes
I'm doing it actually for the after
party for the book launch party am I
invited Chelsea Manning thank you very
much readme.text goes on sale tomorrow
coming up Talk of the table we'll be
right back